our next speaker has lived on three
continents I want to know what three so
when you come down here tell us please
welcome Kim
hello everybody thank you for coming
back for the second day my name is
kamenke I am a data scientist with the
Federal Reserve Bank of Minneapolis and
I am here today to talk to you about a
causal inference method to
um that we use to evaluate the
Minneapolis 2040 comprehensive plan a
little bit different than the other
talks you um seen so far but I hope it's
interesting to you all
if I go any further I want to emphasize
that the views and opinions expressed
today are mine and mine only and not
necessarily those of the Federal Reserve
Bank of Minneapolis or the Federal
Reserve System
so why are we doing this
um so this is the partnership between
the City of Minneapolis and the Federal
Reserve Bank of Minneapolis we
um in 2018 I believe the City of
Minneapolis passed the
2040 comprehensive plan that went into
effect in late 2019 and so for our
purpose when we talk about post
treatment pre-treatment when I say pulse
treatment I really mean 2020 and later
and pre-treatment is 2019 and earlier
the goal of the plan was that by 2040
quality housing throughout the City of
Minneapolis was affordable and
accessible to all Minneapolis residents
regardless of their um race income or um
anything else and with the adoption of
this plan Minneapolis became the first
major U.S city to eliminate zoning
regulations that ban duplexes and
triplexes
um yeah and what used to be single
family detached homes only zoning
so how did we do this there are three
topics um three topic areas of interest
uh So the plan what the plan was the
adoption of the plan
um what we wanted to see was that there
would be more housing um more affordable
housing and also more Equitable housing
there is no one indicator metric or
measure
um that could capture all these three
topic areas and so what we ended up
doing was to develop 10 different
indicators that capture different
aspects of these three topic areas
for each of those um for each of those
10 indicators we estimate the treatment
effect of the plan I'm using uh the
synthetic control method or um sometimes
I'll refer to it as sem
um the sem doesn't really at least um
with the uh the app the air package that
we use to um to implement this it didn't
give us um like a way to assess the
physical significance and so we went one
step further and developed a um all
adapt
um a permanent permutation test to
assess the physical significance so just
a way to calculate p-value so that you
can say whether or not that treatment
effect is you know significant or not
um
all right so before going into talking
about the um like what the methodology
is and how to implement it uh you know
um why do we even consider synthetic
control um traditionally what um people
have done in the past is maybe you know
pick a similar City so we're talking
about Minneapolis um you might be
tempted to say why don't why don't we
just compare to Saint Paul it's close
enough to very similar housing market
and you know it's like maybe it's a good
control um city for Minneapolis uh
but maybe the population makeup is
different culturally it could be
different
um so there are so many things that
could go wrong with just one picking one
city and then you can say why not pick
five cities um you know look maybe look
at like um Chicago or some other cities
that are closer may have like similar um
economy in the housing market and all of
that but then you have to decide do you
want to take simple average or weighted
average and if you do weighted average
on what weight should you give to each
of the city that you pick and how do you
know um that they actually follow the
same patterns that would give you what
we call the counter factual which is the
um you know what uh what the outcome
would have been had the plan not been
implemented and so
um with synthetic control on sem uh what
it allows us to do is to systematically
select the comparison groups and um also
um gives us their weight so we don't
have to make that subjective judgment
which you know could be different
depending on who makes the decision
right
um and then most importantly because it
weighs the control groups to better
match the treatment group before the
intervention so this is um you know 2019
and earlier and I am in our study it
accounts for the effects of the
confounders changing over time so you
know we only have like one second
founder I can't think of right now is
probably the um covet pandemic like you
know just a tiny thing
um that happens to
um uh start at around the same time as
the start of the um implementation of
this plan but the pandemic affected um
of Steel effects
um every city in the U.S and so
um yes maybe the the effect
um the effects may be a little bit
different across different city or very
different but we can assume that it
affects everybody so on average it
should it should not um you know affect
our treatment
um as on treatment effect estimation
that much
but
um
what about events that may only affect
the treatment unit so in this case
Minneapolis so I don't know if you all
have heard but um in summer 2020 there
were some uh the murder of George Floyd
the civil unrest that all started in
Minneapolis so it confounds but um you
know our treatment a little bit but um
at this point
um we're hoping that um you know what we
find um is still valid
that's not really anything we can do
like we can um uh distinguish that um
that effect
um from the plan
all right
um and of course
um as a star session I have to give you
the assumptions before going into
talking about the methodology
uh so the um there are three assumptions
that I want to point out here
um so when you choose your control unit
so sometimes I'll refer to them as donor
series
um they cannot have similar policy
change and the policy of Interest so in
this case the the um the adoption of the
plan cannot affect the outcome in the
control
um cities and so no spillover effect so
we want we want it to be clean
um and then um you know Sam what it
gives us is it calculate the weight so
after the donor Series so what it really
gives us is the weighted average of the
donor cities that then make up the
um the control series or like the path
of um what Minneapolis could have been
had the plan not been implemented and so
one of the assumptions is that that
counterfeitual outcome has um can be a
approximated by a fixed combination of
those donor cities
now but all of that out of the way let's
talk about what sem really is I'm I'm
giving like very conceptual
um uh overview of the methodology I have
a link um in the slide
um that you know links to like much more
technical description of the methodology
all of the mathematical notations
um that I know you all love but I
decided to skip for today
um so first um you want to identify
predictors of the outcome variables so
in this case our outcome variables they
are 10 of them right like we um talk we
I mentioned we um picked 10 different
indicators and
um uh what we didn't want to do is to
customize the process um or the
procedures for each indicator we wanted
it to be General enough that we could
apply to all 10 indicators so we follow
the same one and so then you know trying
to like stay away from like choosing
something that gives us a good outcome
versus like something more General
enough so that like we're not
pre-hucking our way into like a good
outcome
and so um in um in our project we picked
uh
this in the um these predictor so we
have total population home ownership
rate median housing costs median
household income and because again this
is still a Time series we're thinking
enveloping a data over time
um we want to be you know we want to
take into account past values as well
but you also don't want to like use
every single um pre-treatment value to
like fit your model and so we compromise
and use um update like values of the
outcome as predictors
um and then uh the next thing is to
identify potential control units or con
um the donor cities
um as I mentioned earlier you know there
are a few assumptions that we have to
meet and so when we pick um Dona cities
uh those came into our decisions on like
what we like what cities to include as
well
and um I should know this but I think
Minneapolis has the population of about
like between um three to four hundred
thousand people I believe and so it's
like we pick a range of population of
cities to be included you know to like
be somewhat similar to Minneapolis
um and so we chose 150 150 000 to 2
million
um those cities cannot have any policy
um in effect at around the same time
um Portland Oregon
um and then like some um a lot of cities
in California actually like um looked
into like similar uh policy change in
terms of zoning and so we excluded all
of them uh Dona cities also cannot um
have any spill or effects of Saint Paul
um they're not included they're not
including them
um they're not including Saint Paul in
our donor City Pool
um and then um the other two is just you
know with like working with uh um Census
Data it's like they have to be a census
play so that we can pull the data
um and then it's like uh the cities have
to be like one of the main cities like
it can't just be like something random
um yeah
um and then once we have the um
projectors and the uh um Dona series we
can calculate the um predictor rates so
um this um these are the weights uh yeah
so um
these are the weights that go into the
next optimization problem to give us the
control City weights so um they're not
this is not like the weights that
they're using to estimate um to get the
um weighted average of the control
series but it's important because it
goes into that optimization problem
um there are two ways that um uh are
implemented in the package that we use
that I'm going to talk um about in a
little bit
um so one is to give it equal weight so
if we have 10 um if we have 10
predictors um each one would get one
tenth um and then the other one is
regression based weights um so this is
where all of the data is like the
predictors data and the outcome data
over time um pre um all of the
pre-treatment data um get
um put into like a regression
um a regression model and then it spits
out of weight for each of the predictors
um against like all of the technical
um uh detail on this um uh is in like
the technical appendix that um I'll
share the link to later
and then finally it's like once you have
the protectors um predicted weights um
you can
put them into the optimization problem
and then say what you wanna what it does
is it minimizes the root mean squared
error um it you try to minimize the root
mean Square prediction error inside
whichever method on whichever
um set of predicted with unpredictable
weights that gives you the least rmse
that um and then um the
that will give you the um final
um uh control City weight that then goes
into your weighted average to get your
synthetic control series on the counter
factual I'm skipping out I'm skipping
over on a lot of details um there's so
much more detail in the technical index
but
um yeah so let's say so these are kind
of like the steps that we um can do to
implement this um method and then once
we get the weights we can calculate the
count of actual
um uh post treatment
and then
um what we and then next thing is we do
the statistical
um assessing the um statistical
significance so calculating p-value we
all love p-value right like it has to be
below zero point of um 0.05 I don't
believe that but um yeah
um but we have to pick a cut off uh um
we actually use point on point one in uh
um in our project but yeah so um to do
I'm running out of pants I'm gonna go
through this very quickly uh so two um
calculate P value what you want to do is
running the same um running the same sem
on audio control series and then
calculate the imsd post treatment to
pre-treatment so
um if the if sem fits your data well so
this would be like for the control
series there's no um there's no plan in
effect so they should fit pretty well
and so the ratio the rmse the post to
pre-treatment imsd ratio should be
pretty small
um for Minneapolis if there is an effect
um the rmsc ratio should be larger
because now um right like it fits well
in the pre-treatment but it does not um
fit well post treatment that means
there's an impact of the plan and so
then to get to get to the p-value um in
a way you can think of it as like
ranking each of the each of the control
cities in Minneapolis so we have 126
control cities that met the criteria I
talked about about and then Minneapolis
so 127 and let's say Minneapolis has the
10th largest imsa ratio of all the
control of all the cities that would
give us a p-value of 10 divided by 127
which is around 0.08
um so that's how we cut um that's how we
did our statistical significance
assessment
so not the implementation
um so this is one of the 10 indicators
that we
um uh study uh so this is housing cost
but then among extremely low income
renting households pass burden means you
spend 30 or more of your household
income on housing EX on housing expense
and extremely low incomes
um extremely low income households are
households that earn 30 or less of the
area median income just a little plot to
show you it's like this is the data for
Minneapolis that we have
the package that we use to implement sem
is synth so synth implements the data
control methods for comparative case
studies designed to estimate the causal
effects of policy interventions and
other events of interest
um you can do you can just do the
installed up packages and then like load
using Library just like any other AD
packages that you use
um and then so I want to give like a
little look into the data that go in
that end up going into the um actual um
function so our unit
um our time variable is year and then I
use our unit variable is um uh City and
so that would be like the place ID
um so it's called place because we're
using census data and then the input
data have to be
um they have to be unique the roles have
to be unique and the time variable and
the unit variable so we have 13 years of
data and 127 cities so the row the
number of rows should be um 13 times 127
we cannot have missing values at least
um in um for the yeah we cannot have
missing values for the outcomes of
interest and then we talked about
predictors so here I have all those on
four predictors um here also go into
um go into the function later
but before
um oh and sorry it got cut off a little
um it was fine when I looked at it this
morning so I apologize but
um before going um before running sem on
this we want to put the data from like a
regular data frame into the data prep
object
um so data prep function is um from the
synth um package and so you
um what we did here is giving it the
data so that input data is what we just
saw
um and then the column names for the
projectors um column names for the
dependent variable so that's the outcome
column names for the unit and time
variables um the special predictors are
the lag values that we talked about
earlier and then like below here if you
could see it um so it's like you give it
like the pre-treatment period that you
want the algorithm to optimize
um used for the optimization
and then um also it's like the ID for
like the control and for the um for the
treatment unit and the control units
um and then so and from that um it's one
line of code really so you just run it
through synth and it does all of the
magic and then gives you
um what you see here with just another
line of code to show you how the model
um how sem um fits with your data
out of the box chats are nice but
sometimes they don't give you um what
you want so for example here I mean it's
like if you're working in base Iris like
you can add stuff to this but who works
in base are we all love ggplot so that's
what we do
um but but a little bit additional um
code like you can um I use data table
and I'm realizing that a lot of people
are that um people but this is some data
table syntax
um but I love the ggplot
um to package so you know extract the
weights and then like try um and then we
can put it into this is not that great
but better than the um out of the box
chant
um and then here's just a little bit of
code again and they had that table
syntax calculating the p-value using the
methodology that I um mentioned earlier
um of described earlier and um yeah and
then once we have the um uh right like
the series we can visualize it and then
we have the p-value to let us know
whether or not there's actually
um uh whether or not the difference we
see between the counter factual and the
actual outcome is statistically
significant
um now we are ready to um communicate
that to our stakeholders
um and of course I'm very very happy to
go after Mali because we have a shiny
app
so um we put everything into shiny app
this is actually um public and where
like we have been um updating it
regularly um as data come in and um yeah
and so this is our final product that
lives on our website
so now you might be asking what is the
effect of the plan now I have not talked
about that at all
um So the plan went to effect went into
effect in 2020
um you know a lot happened right Census
Data was a mess
um like so a lot of things happen and
it's only it's still only 2022 so we
don't actually have a lot of data to
really um sufficiently estimate the
treatment effect yet but we kind of see
this um like we wanted to make this
public because uh you know it's a way to
monitor how things change over time not
just the in the 10 indicators we also
have like additional
um contextual information that our
stakeholders are interested in and then
it's a way for us to pre-register our
methodology so that when we do have the
data we're not engineering it so that it
fits um the outcome that we want to see
last slide um and then so this is just
the link and that the third one is the
technical appendix that I mentioned so
all of the math that you want to see
um and then um uh here's the um that's
the link to the slide it's live on our
Pops and with that um thank you and uh
talk to me if you have any questions